spero che questo mi aiuti ho comprato un
altra cosa un tappeto e bellissimo vero
sono oggi giocheremo finalmente a una
richiesta a ruota che giochiamo abbiamo
solo giocato un'altra volta a pighi se
ve lo ricordate scriveteci nei commenti
sicuramente faremo un disastro non
sapremo bene cose morale se avete
consigli su che giochi provare su rob
lowe che mappe provare scrivete nei
commenti
e questo video raggiunge i 10 mila mi
piace faremo un altro episodio quindi
forni giocare qua sotto
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn e
proseguiti ancora sagra mandati a
seguirmi il nome ha lasciato mi piace
qui sotto e iniziamo subito tech sicura
questo parco di divertimenti oro
all'iniziativa in una spiaggia google al
cielo che paura allora questo è il mio
personaggio vi piace non capisco ancora
bene come funziona con i vestiti non
sono riusciti a togliere i jeans perché
ho in realtà ho preso un vestito ma il
gesto rimangono non lo so perché ed ecco
vitale giorno vestito vip rivestiti che
ho trovato ad evitare vestito buone a
questo personaggio qua questo
personaggio appena detto ehi questo
parco di divertimenti sembra molto
pauroso pronti per entrare
andiamo su emozionata mi sembra di
entrare davvero in un parco di
divertimento guardate ci fu un castello
wow
ok è bravo cosa dobbiamo fare questi
sono i costumi invece guarda aspettano
tiro graziosa in vendita un numero che
paura questo personaggio che sei un
pagliaccio
e qui c'è una strega basta dobbiamo fare
dobbiamo prendere i biglietti no questi
non parlano penso che possiamo entrare
ecco qua che cos'è questo ma con in
questi pulsanti se non sbaglio salvi il
gioco posso aiuto stai dicendo diventare
inquietante vorrebbe una ruota ma sembra
un pagliaccio diceva ma perché stiamo
saltando su un burger
ma ne dice di salire sopra la ruota
panoramica e si può vedere tutto il
parco da sopra ma perché essi sono
queste questo rumore di esplosioni che
paura e non fai saltato la fila è
saltata la trattativa però guarda che
bello posso fare
guardare c'è un camion e poi subito pure
io e basta in un altro governo tutto
questo parco che io torno adesso essendo
equa dobbiamo ha promesso che paura
dobbiamo stare attenti ai palloncini
stocastici calcio over umane sono rinata
d'acqua
io invece sono riuscito a passare magno
kremlin per come incredibili ok ok ho
preso un premi dov'è note che carina
umano mi segue
bellissimo come vivano chiamerò ghismo
attenti attenti attenti ma tutte queste
io l'ho già passato tutti cosa sono
certi ma è attento
segnano per saltare sulle caramelle si
guasta sono morto può sfruttare sopra
questo scopo di porre potter
quindi ha subito lo stop a buffon ho
pregato e come tipo de flore slava
bisogna state superate
ok zombie corriamo la palla un cimitero
è guerra si sono utilizzo un vita rimane
non ci dobbiamo far prendere dagli
zombie scappa corri stop shop di un
fantasma anche li portano a casa che può
murano che strega perché dobbiamo andare
con circa di se l'abbiamo fatta così che
mi sia stato facile comunque da questo
quadro troppo io do le cose con 9 mar
il fatto di base c'è una stanza stregata
ma si mangia aveva venduto i piatti
basta tutto sono dei fantasmi bellissimo
che cosa bisogna guardare dei
pipistrelli vitale sta cercando il
cimone inviato ha detto qualcuno ha
scritto nel camino berry è stato qua ma
chi è barry
forse dovevo risolvere un mistero dentro
questa casa stregata 36 non entrare in
questa borsa c'erano degli inizi con la
è fatto così cercare sogna stare attenti
provo più che il piano organico devi
stare attento tempo in piazza allora
vediamo vediamo tedesco passare in tempo
no vabbè cambiare il suo ok sollecita a
passare il primo non glielo posso fare
solo dai tagli sbrigati d'angelo ma non
ce la fai sì che ce la fai
bravo bravo ti conviene passare più
verso il centro però ce la possa fare ce
la posso fare
sei sicuro
wow
stanza piena di fantasmi si guarda
stanno ballando o no ma anche a vigilare
il fantasma sul balcone diceva guarda
c'è anche una persona che suona il
pianoforte che un fantasma anche lui ma
bellissima perché stare non è difficile
godiamoci lo spettacolo dove dobbiamo
andare guarda c'è la porta un balcone
che kakà automi che se da un quadro
quindi bisogna stare attenti a non farsi
pronto attento non avvicinarti i quadri
che cos'è ma non bisogna andare
aspetto di io salvo qualche sono dei
pipistrelli qua aspettavi che arrivò no
ma sempre nello stesso punto ai sbrigati
vediamo ora andiamo a vedere vitale che
muore ma siamo più le porte sono
separati e così con altre due persone
che come si fa a me l'ha fatto ok
superati pipistrelli abbina la scelta ci
sono quasi questa persona mi ha detto no
degli zombie che devo scappare le 2 6 3
beh io controlla cosa c'è qua un quadro
teletubbies
non è che l'ultimo pipistrello ma non
alberati che belli questi quadri paurosi
gli zombie sono qui dietro di te ci sono
delle persone che aspettano però non può
arrabbiate fornito che abbiamo superate
c quadri strani sono belli paurosi ok
pensa che dovevo entrare qua ok che si
sta facendo l'abbiamo fatta prima tu ho
paura ma tu dove sei seduto non lo so
sarete molto d'aiuto che paura
aspetta aspetta di vedere questo
progetto si sa bene o no per cadere giù
e tu cosa ci facevi la ho finito prima
il giro a questa persona mi ha detto hai
visto il mostro gigante sì l'abbiamo
visto ok c'è poi facciamo sulla spiaggia
ci sono i granchi giganti sbaglia ha
detto che non sono molto amichevoli
sembrano amichevoli attento e vitali sta
guardando male io cammino quali è meglio
che mi lavoro sotto al muro aiuto
devo salvare questo era abbastanza
semplice dice che dobbiamo saltare quasi
collasso
no sono finita sott'acqua
qui stiamo andando sul galeone a tor
mostro grandi queste mappe di rob lowe
sono altro vitale no sono bellissime
come che non abbiamo scoperto prima
questo gioco è bellissimo insegnateci
anche voi delle cose da fare ma finora
questo era fantastica no no no
ok riproviamoci lo sto ricominciando
[Musica]
quindi non bisogna salire sul galeone
bisogna salire su questa barca
no perché no quali qualora purtroppo può
non salva quindi dobbiamo affrontare gli
squali senza aver salvato aiuto aiuto
perché sale
youtube dove l'altro no ok ho preso una
cosa che sembrano spero che mi aiuti
spero che questo mi aiuti a butterato
vedevo sereno ce la vediamo no ma
pensavo che questa volta mi pozzetto
arrivare prima bene ho preso un comprato
un oggetto per nessun motivo non so
perché mi consigliava di prenderlo forse
posso provare usarla d'acqua vediamo
barca non potete capire quante volte ti
ho trovato ma tanto adesso amori o
miseramente
forse funziona il salvataggio adesso no
perché è illuminato prima neve cosa
volevi salvare non vincerò mai per gli
squali se con la molla per evitare gli
squali e un po rischioso però possiamo
provare
bellissimo
ho comprato un altra cosa un tappeto e
bellissimo vero bettino qui sulla sabbia
se lo metti dire è un tappeto non un
sottomarino
vabbè io spero veramente che ho capito
che succede guarda lascia un arcobaleno
dietro di me
ok ho capito ha beccate vico è
bellissimo
[Musica]
non mi potete prendere d'acqua ma questo
è un passaggio tutto tappeto volante
arcobaleno festari e vengo a prenderti
dice wow ma è stupendo altro che quella
molla per saltare aspettami provata lire
l'altro qua a parigi ciao ciao
wow era questo che bello
ok salviamo qua è il cappello forse no
passando al mare evviva ho superato
tutto grazie al mio tappe guai dice che
vuole salire guarda se tipo una montagna
russa con l'acqua come marzo sbaglio o
c'è uno squalo lì non venaria una scuola
che vola marino adoro questo parco
divertimenti estate passo prevede la
bacchetta e con la scuola che ti dice
bocca dello squalo aiuto mi dispiace che
non ci sei tu con me sarà impossibile
superare quel passaggio proprio un vero
e proprio parco di divertimenti vorrei
che esiste vorrei che si stesse davvero
per poterci andare davvero
e tutto un parco di divertimenti tutto
paura che bello aiuto dove dove stiamo
andando
[Musica]
ok tanto discendere forza
si ok mandare qua speriamo di poter
salvare mabar che non mi muovo salvare
dove devo andare guerra qui c'è la
partita degli scheletri è ok vediamo
cosa dice se dice di prendere
l'ascensore velato prevede che paura che
andiamo dovrebbe certamente un panorama
spettacolare anche se siete perché tutto
quello che succede minuto papa
adesso ricomincia per fare il papà è no
perché io e il mio caffè è così imparate
a non farmi salvare il lavoro il mio
cappello
ciao ciao poi andare direttamente in
cibo sbatterti comunque questo tappeto
volante fantastico a 30 youtube dove
devo andare
noi per l'uso migliori salire sul
tappeto wow aiuto
guarda sono sulla testa di una casa alla
giusta testa del teschio che devo andare
adesso guarda tutto il parco
stupendo no veramente il tappeto è
meraviglioso forse devo andare qua c'è
qualcuno cosa perché avremo la montagna
si no 9 questo è troppo bello quindi
bisognerà salire finissima per poi
scendere a gela nella palla trasparente
no vabbè che succede salotto
forse è finito ma ne ho capito adesso
forse puoi scendere se ieri
non posso salvare neanche qua dove
bisogna andare adesso qua è chiuso ma io
mi aspetta aspetta tutto sta dettando
nel castello di degli orrori come sarà
andiamo
adoro vediamo saliamo prime forma di
pallottola bellissimo legittimo tutto il
castello che bello ma erano bellissimi
questa montagna e robuste ore lo
schiererò forse questa è l'ultima tappa
di questo parco di divertimento e un
motoscafo
vediamo cosa si dice si dice di prendere
la palla e tu che avventura che è stata
prendiamo la barca per andare via non
voglio guidare
peccato che non c'è più vita batterti
ovviamente non potrà saldare neanche qua
forse fa bravi sopravvissuto al parco di
divertimento bra e cosa dobbiamo fare
info tel
ho preso un badge che dice che ho vinto
ieri
e bello cuore sia rimasta veramente a
bocca aperta da quanto era bella questa
mappa di rollo non pensavo che il gioco
rob lux fosse così bello per me chi o
cosa non esaltante mappe così
incredibile esplorare un po felice
consigliate se le altre mappe qua sotto
lasciate un mi piace facciamo sentire
sicura vi piace e ora vi lasciamo con di
cliccare per vedere i vostri altri video
cade su quella che preferite